Hong Kong activists say their freedoms
are being eroded forever Beijing says
the law is necessary for the city to
prosper and that many countries welcome
this on behalf of 53 countries Cuba
welcomes the law of the People's
Republic of China on safeguarding
national security in Hong Kong at the
session of the United Nations Human
Rights Council they believe that the law
will help to sustain and steady
implementation of one country two
systems'
a principle within which a high degree
of autonomy was supposed to be
guaranteed in Hong Kong for at least 50
years when Britain handed back its
former colony to China in 1997 the new
law is a flagrant breach of the
agreement says the city's last UK
governor together starting a new cold
war with China but just making
absolutely clear that we will call out
China when it behaves badly the UK now
says it would uphold his historic duty
and offer a route for up to three
million residents to settle in the
country that could make citizenship
possible across the Atlantic the US has
punitive Lee revoked Hong Kong's special
financial and business status Washington
says it's not only concerned about the
safety of Hong Kong s but also that of
Americans article 38 of the new law also
purports to apply to offenses committed
outside of Hong Kong by non-residents of
Hong Kong and this likely includes
Americans this is outrageous and an
affront to all nations
the yyyy-you meanwhile has said it's
discussing with international partners
possible measures in response German
Foreign Minister Heiko Maas has called
developments in Hong Kong exceptionally
worrying
these protesters are worried too but
they've pledged to try as hard as they
can to keep their voices heard and let's
get more on that we are joined now by
Phoebe Kong who is driving us from Hong
Kong Phoebe we just heard about this
offer of a path to citizenship from the
UK for Hong Kong residents what's been
the reaction and are people likely to
take them up on that
wisely there has been a growing trend
and aspiration of immigration in Hong
Kong over the past few years followed by
a series of political and the rest and
encroachment so the new lifeboat schemes
from the UK will like simply offer an
utter and incentive for this case for
for the people who want to move away
from Hong Kong
especially those a middle class more
educated and professionals and the
families with young children so they are
the people were like for to like move
overseas like to weigh a fly the
original a way of life but on the other
hand as we observed in moving Hong Kong
quite a lot of young people especially
those who were born after 1997 we don't
have any colonial passport quite
numerous and they want to stay here for
the fight so we see there's a polarized
sentiment here in Hong Kong but
definitely the new our citizenship
scheme from UK would be another option
for Hong Kong people and more people now
applying to renew the our petition at
know that these Hathor as an exit for
them and the polarization the resistance
visible on the streets yesterday we know
hundreds of people were arrested what is
likely to happen today
well things have been cool down a little
bit after the anniversary rally
yesterday and this is what we expected
for the coming few days they after the
massive and the iconic protest the
street protest will cool down a little
bit and another reason is that it's
simply too risky for people to take the
streets right now yesterday 10 people
who were arrested for for the charge of
the national security of fences so
almost all of them as they were just
like possessing and holding
pro-independence logan's or like other
anti-government slogans so today we saw
a similar of actions and out going on
so I think the street protest is getting
more risky and people will step back a
bit and the social and political
activism may transform in a little in
another way to our proceed in the future
correspondent Phoebe Kong in Hong Kong
thank you and DW correspondent Georg
mattis is following the story frost he
has the reaction from Brussels Georg
we've been seeing this international
reaction to the new national security
law in Hong Kong it's been mixed
where does Brussels stand there are not
a lot of pressure coming from Brussels
in a way you rather have the expected
statements you had Joseph Corral the
foreign policy chief as saying that it
was essential that existing rights
remain observed in Hong Kong you had was
Olaf underlined the head of the European
Commission adding that national security
law does not conform with Hong Kong
basic law and that they are seriously
concerned about it and seriously
concerned about it says it all there's
no implications of sanctions foreign
ministers debated that in the last
meeting in May and they came to the
conclusion that it was not applicable
because it would not solve the problem
why is the EU not doing more Oh a number
of reason really here when it comes to
foreign policy there this is not the
sharpest tool of the EU a foreign policy
falls within the individual member
states the sovereignty of those 27
member states and their various
interests big economic interests of
course including Germany and
of course you have brexit and you the EU
has lost I would say one of its most
committed members when it comes to the
question of Hong Kong which is the UK
and then finally you have the corona
crisis and here really you have a
situation rather you currently is trying
to put together a rescue fund and the
last thing they need or the last thing
the German presidency which started
yesterday I wants to see is a Rao an
economic Rao over sanctions with China
so it's all about the money meantime how
is Europe viewing the latest movement in
terms of human rights and and basic
fundamental freedoms of course human
rights is a particular field that has
been of course addressed by EU officials
so a 27 country declaration urges China
to avoid undermining Hong Kong's
autonomy and particularly emphasizes a
civil and political rights and that is
also the argument that the US for
instance has put forward although they
are much closer to sanctions than the EU
now the difference being many observers
have said is simply that the u.s. is
almost on the edge of a trade war if not
a cold war with China and the EU is
trying to avoid exactly that being drawn
into that conflict
Georg mattis in Brussels thank you Hong
Kong is one of the world's financial
hubs of course even as mainland markets
like Shenzhen and Shanghai have grown
rich Hong Kong is still seen as the
Gateway to financial markets in China
and the rest of Asia but that too is now
under threat over the past few decades
two trends have shaped the fortunes of
Hong Kong one is the rise in Chinese
wealth the other the boom in global
finance when these two currents
converged Hong Kong grew rich but months
of unrest driven by pro-democracy
protests and now the introduction of a
new security law have raised fears that
could all change among the concerns that
capital will leave as China tightens its
grip the talent will go and that
Enterprise itself will leave
have suggested that some international
firms would consider moving regional
offices depending on the implementation
of the law so far there's been little
evidence to support those fears more
capital has entered Hong Kong in recent
months and has left it
thanks to China's deep pockets local
businesses have by and large given their
blessing to the new law and even larger
firms like Britain's HSBC appear ready
to accept it adding to the wind in Hong
Kong sales more Chinese companies are
likely to list on the city's exchange as
new US rules make Chinese IPOs they're
more difficult
let's bring in business correspondent
Clifford Coonan who's joining us here in
the studio how much longer can Hong Kong
remain a financial hub well this is the
big question I mean this is this is the
law here and I've been going through it
and over the last of the last day or so
and talking to analysts and what they're
saying is generally that they feel that
there is a real danger that Hong Kong
could become just like another Chinese
city that this law will be quite good
for domestic listings and for companies
that have a big interest in China but
the International dimension is under
threat and I think that's where we're
really looking at in in ten years we've
we've you know we're not going to see
pictures like we've seen pictures of
protests and I can't really see that
happening in ten years time so there's a
lot of a lot of fear around the moment a
lot of uncertainty where will the money
go where will the people though well
we've seen that someone go to maybe go
to Britain and Australia has also said
that it's going to take some people
capital at the moment
the question that people are saying if I
need to have my money why would I have
it in Hong Kong when there's now
uncertainty when the heavy hand of China
is in evidence when I could put it in
place like Singapore and also Taiwan
Taiwan is emerging again as the place
where a lot of people will be looking
and I think we're gonna see a lot of
growth there too what are you making of
the International reaction it's been
very interesting I mean the US has been
was very quick to move the EU as we just
heard has been
has been quick to condemn but hasn't
really done anything yet I think for a
long time people have been enjoying the
economic growth that we've seen in China
and they wanted a piece of that but what
we haven't really seen is people
realizing that that comes at a certain
cost and one of those costs is the
notion of freedom and democracy in Hong
Kong so increasingly you're going to see
people having to weigh up these things
and when we have you look at some
analysts we're saying yesterday that
maybe people are going to start looking
at the Hong Kong question and asking is
it going to be like investing in tobacco
in the 70s is suddenly investing in
China going to come at a cost
China's becoming incredibly aggressive
in in the last few months it's under
cover of covert it's introduced various
measures so possibly I think that we
could see real changes in that way and
and a different way of thinking about
how investing in China happens largely
driven by the Hong Kong situation so the
name of the game going forward
uncertainty Clifford Coonan from DW
business thank you